the arrest of David Miranda was seen as
an act of intimidation by defenders of
press freedom the partner of glenn
greenwald a journalist who published
allegations concerning the United States
surveillance program was held for nine
hours this summer by the British
authorities he confiscated his personal
belongings freedom of the media is
clearly under threat because when there
is harassment and intimidation they will
have a chilling effect on the media it
will lead to self-censorship this is an
ongoing investigation it is not an
opinion of a journalist it is a theft
finally I'd like to remind the house
that we're here to serve the interests
of citizens in the EU not just a few
vocal bloggers hackers and Twitterers to
seem to have a powerful lobby here in
the parliament should environmental
impact studies be carried out or not the
questions on hold in the European
Parliament updating a list of over 200
public and private projects that are
subject to mandatory environmental
impact studies is being debated by mep s
should shale gas fracking be subject
impact assessments to de Graaf see
projected le général in okla re le
disque re que le cadre punt led gay
yarrow portis Oh No sogeti evaluacion LD
in patent meant ra y que tanto / qui t'a
anche lo hagas de vez el susto posto
quest approach adoro SI sono di Costilla
sauce dinero pero y Coastie que la
generación in future a potrebbero sus
tener a causa de dani ambiente Powter
bro esse Clemente molto Maggiore quindi
a min or da know the issue hasn't been
resolved and avoid has been postponed
antigua
think back to october and november 2012
when part of europe was underwater
slovenia croatia and austria was
severely affected by flooding the
Parliament on Wednesday approved a
European solidarity fund to help to
repair the damage nearly 14.6 million
euros will be made available of which 14
million alpha slovenia alone